Speaker 1: This is just an unbelievable instance
of spin when it comes to January six.
So we've talked a lot about this hearing that
took place yesterday.
We started at the beginning of the show with
the statements made by Biden administration
officials about the greatest domestic terror
threat in the United States, which Merrick
Garland and others believe is white supremacist
domestic terror.
And I believe the numbers confirm that that's
the case.
We also learned just in the last segment because
of Donald Trump's former acting secretary
of defense, that more than three hours went
by between when the riots started and when
there was finally an authorization given for
the National Guard to clear the Capitol.
We then saw questioning from Republican Congressman
Jody Hice where he argued that the real victims
on January 6th, it wasn't the American people,
it wasn't the police.
In Washington, D.C., the real victims on January
6th, says Jodi Heise, were trumpet's who were
there in support of Donald Trump.
I know Republican Congressman Jody Hice is
not exactly a brilliant guy.
And this is the case he tried to make during
yesterday's hearings.
You really have to be capable of some incredible
revisionist history and departures from logic
to even try to claim this.
But Jodi Hice tries to play some of the lead
up here in this video and then look at how
he tries to portray the Trump rioters as the
real victims
Speaker 3: between 110 and 115.
President Trump ends his speech and tells
attendees to peacefully and patriotically
make their voices heard at the Capitol.
About 150.
The capital is breached.
Now, in this timeline, it would have been
about two o'clock before the earliest.
Attendees of
Speaker 1: Trump's speech could have arrived
at the Capitol,
Speaker 3: so the Capitol is attacked at the
right.
Shortly after the president begins his speech,
it's breached before individuals could have
gotten there.
Where is the real narrative in all of that?
Another narrative I want to bring up is that
the the media claims that the tragic death
of Officer Brian Cygnet was a result of pro
Trump mobs bashing his skull with a fire extinguisher,
which we all know now did not happen.
Officer Cygnet, his autopsy revealed that
he suffered no blunt trauma.
In fact, his mother has since come out saying
he died of a stroke.
In fact, it was Trump supporters who lost
their lives that day, not Trump supporters
who were taking the lives of others.
You go down the list here.
Ashleigh Babbitt was shot and killed by a
Capitol Police officer.
Kevin Greeson suffered a heart attack.
Rosann Boyland reportedly was crushed by rioters
and Benjamin Phillips died of a stroke.
So the narrative needs to be cleared up.
The truth matters.
Speaker 1: The people he's naming that died
died because they chose to be there in direct
violation of the law.
I don't think any death is to be celebrated
here.
People who have been watching the show know
that that's always been my perspective.
But look at the people that he's naming.
He names Ashleigh Babbitt, who was shot by
police.
While that's true, Babbitt was one of the
many military service members who went to
the riots against the law trespassing.
Police officers have been cleared of wrongdoing
in her death.
She was shot while trying to breach doors
within the Capitol.
She was already trespassing.
She has already broken the law merely by being
in there.
She was trying to breach further doors in
the Capitol and the officer has been cleared
because he believed he was acting in self-defense
and the defense of members of Congress that
he was sworn to protect.
In any other scenario, these right wingers
would be saying that was a justifiable police
shooting.
In this case, they're saying the trumpets
were the victims.
Here he mentions Kevin Greeson.
Kevin Greeson suffered a heart attack.
That's true.
Kevin Greason was there, suffered a heart
attack reportedly after tasing himself while
allegedly trying to steal a painting from
the Capitol.
He shouldn't even have been there.
He was committing a crime by being there.
He got his hands on a Taser.
He chased himself and subsequently had a heart
attack.
That's not a Trump supporter being a victim.
That's a criminal for whom their criminal
acts went wrong.
And we're not celebrating the death.
But to say that that proves that the Trump
ists are victims not a very accurate statement
to make.
Jody Hice mentioned Roseanne Boyland.
Roseanne Boyland was crushed by rioters.
That is completely true.
She was crushed by a stampede of Trump hosts,
of which she was a part as they were all breaking
into the capital.
It's sad, but why was she there?
She was there breaking the law along with
these other Trump who trampled her.
It's horrible, but that's what happened.
And then lastly, Jody Hice mentions Benjamin
Phillips.
Benjamin Phillips died of a stroke.
He says that's true.
He was there breaking the law as well.
He wasn't killed by antifa.
He wasn't killed by police.
And to frame trumpet's as victims who were
minding their own business, just looking at
the capital, and then were killed either by
police or by antifa or left wingers to frame
them that way rather than as the perpetrators
that they are of a seditious attempt to overturn
the election is just pathetic.
But Jody Hice is exactly the type of guy who
would try it.
I'm not going to give you his full kind of
greatest hits.
You can go back in our archives and find some
of the horrible things that Jody Hice has
said over the last decade.
But it's a degree of spin that should really
make anybody dizzy.
It's a sort of war is peace.
Freedom is slavery like it's that type of
misinformation.
These were not invited guests who were just
looking at a painting at the Capitol and then
they were run over by a mob.
They were trespassing as part of that mob.
And I'm trying to remember the line that conservatives
often use after police shootings, at least
as it refers to Ashley Babbitt.
And they say stuff like, you know, if they
just followed the law and orders from police,
no one of what, nobody would have gotten shot,
hurt or killed or whatever the case may be
that it applies to Ashley Babbitt.
I'm not glad she died, but this is the logic
that they give us whenever there's a police
shooting that we look at and we say that seems
insane.
That seems like the police did something wrong.
They just they were breaking the law already.
They were criminals.
They weren't listening to what police were
saying an.
Also, by the way, the the version of events
that Jody Hice is kind of trying to present
here, it's almost like he doesn't realize
there's video of the entire thing.
We saw how it all went down and it makes it
even more pathetic.
But he doesn't care.
And this guy really is one of the most pathetic
members of Congress out there.
Just check out go to my YouTube channel, just
go to YouTube and type Jody Hice David Pakman
and you'll see his long track record
of absurdity.